david xavier weiss bonjour bonjour dieu
d'or excellent bonjour
bonjour merci pour l'invitation merci à
tous les deux d'avoir accepté de venir
échanger débattre ce matin sur rtl
france au lendemain de ce meeting de
valérie pécresse un meeting donc pour
relancer la candidate ait l'air selon
les sondages valérie pécresse marine le
pen et l'église et moore sont dans un
mouchoir de poche pour l'accession au
second tour un faso au président sortant
emmanuel macron pour commencer alors ce
discours d'une heure vingt est ce qu'il
fera date selon vous faites france
pardonnez moi là david xavier weiss
pardonnez moi il freine moi c'est pas
tant sur le fond je trouve que
l'opération séduction a bien marché hier
il ya des plus plus de 8000 personnes
traitées au zénith et à côté des soins a
ouvert une salle à côté puisqu'il
manquait la base au zénith le zénith
était plein l'opération séduction pour
la droite et le centre a réellement bien
marché puisque voilà tous les ténors de
la droite étaient présents tous les
ténors du centre étaient présentes et
beaucoup de militants beaucoup de
militants ont fait des trajets très
lourd parfois pour venir soutenir la
candidate valérie pécresse et au delà au
delà du fonds qui étaient très bons sur
les choses qui ont été égrénés comme
comme différents thèmes de campagne
l'ambiance était présente contrairement
à ce qu'ont pu certains ont pu dire
certains journalistes et commentateurs
hier david xavier weiss donc
enthousiasme après ce meeting dionewar
excellent qu'est ce que vous avez
observé une frappe date ce meeting selon
vous
non ce n'est pas du tout parce que au
delà de l'ambiance il faut le rappeler
quand même il s'agit d'une élection
présidentielle il s'agit pas de
mobiliser ses militants ses
sympathisants ses fans c'est d'être en
capacité d'incarner roger d'incarner
convient on le paie guinée aujourd'hui
moi je constate qu'une fois de plus pour
plusieurs raisons mal intégrés c'est en
difficulté parce que aujourd'hui il ya
d'autres candidats qui incarne cette
même droite quels sont le défendre
notamment le plaisir emmanuel macron et
les autres candidats qui sont à
l'extrême droite et qui qui sont aussi
qui se partagent un petit peu le même
électorat donc je pourrais vous
l'expliquer sans plus de raison donc
pour moi n'ont rien nouveau sous le
soleil encore des petites phrases encore
une chasse à l'électorat de l'extrême
droite notamment reprenant les thèmes du
remplacement on a l'habitude avec daniel
pécresse il ya un manque de charisme
aussi un qui a été dénoncé dans son
propre camp notamment et avant ce
meeting par par rachida dati regardez
aujourd'hui il est clair qu'il faut
ouvrir une seconde étape dans cette
campagne celle de l'incarnation qui
parle à tous les français il s'agit pour
valérie pécresse d'incarner ce besoin et
cette attente d'autorité les français
doivent avoir le sentiment qu'elle le
fera il faut résister aux postures
technocratique david xavier weiss est ce
que il y a eu effectivement un manque
d'incarnation pour un projet pour un cap
hier selon vous n'aurez pas de manque
d'incarnation vous avez grèce tout le
monde la connaît depuis maintenant plus
de quinze ans on sait de quoi il est
capable on sait qu'elle a lorsqu'elle a
été ministre de nicolas sarkozy puis
depuis maintenant plus de six ans on
peut président de région on sait de quoi
elle est capable elles n'ont pas de
carrizo sinon elle ne serait pas arrivé
là où elle est c'est à dire bah
potentiellement en capacité de battre
mais il m'a tout moi je veux bien
entendu toutes les critiques et est tant
mieux même celles qui viennent de notre
propos quand ce bien sûr les critiques
constructives c'est très bien on voulait
prendre les d'antan mais je prends
aujourd'hui qu'il faut maintenant voilà
passé passé la seconde où lille mais les
mauvaises critiques et les petites
phrases et puis va se mettre en ordre de
bataille ce qui a été le cas hier hier
je lui dis encore une fois on a réuni
plus de 1000 personnes aux ennemis c'est
une démonstration de force et ce qui
était attendu voilà ça dépasse nos
espérances aujourd'hui les thèmes de
campagne vont être égrenés jusqu'au
jusqu'au 2 avril il reste 55 jours utile
pour gagner cette élection on va pas
s'arrêter aux petites phrases et tant
mieux en mieux qui les critiquent encore
une fois qu'ils ont ce qui fait qu'ils
sont prises en compte encore une fois
rachida dati a tout à fait le droit de
s'exprimer elle ne se gêne pas pour le
faire
et souvent il est écouté un dans l'est
dans l'est dans l'est dans les réunions
de campagne
on va pas s'arrêter sur les petites
phrases du lot excellent est là elle a
surtout attaqué emmanuel macron 1
finalement hier dans ce meeting mais la
ligue pécresse pourquoi pour pour mieux
s'en détacher finalement
le vrai souci de montrer c'est toujours
dur pour moi quand même parler d'une
candidate que je ne soutiens pas moi je
ne suis pas là pour lui donner conseils
mais aujourd'hui oui pas de vision des
petites phrases et aujourd'hui son vrai
problème c'est premièrement emmanuel
macron incarne la droite aujourd'hui
parce que c'est un président de droite
vous prenez les électeurs qui ont voté
fillon en 2010 7 47% de ses électeurs
voudraient ce que seulement 47% vote
aurait pécresse donc elle récupère pas
ses pectoraux les parmi cet électorat on
a plus de 20 6% qui vous feront manuel
maintenant aujourd'hui emmanuel masson
est considérée parmi ses troupes
sympathisants comme un candidat de
droite donc elle à une concurrence à
droite qui est réel et la stratégie bien
sûr des manuels macron c'est de
déstabiliser valérie pécresse parce que
pour lui elle représente un danger et on
voit que ça fonctionne ce n'est pas rien
le fait que plusieurs ténors des
républicains partent rejoindre
emmanuel macron l'ancien président de la
république du son propre camp pour ne
pas le citer lui-même ne me dit qu'elle
est une bonne candidate
il le dit pas clairement on sent pas qui
est un soutien franc et aujourd'hui je
sens pas que cette personne incarne
cette vision les petites phrases ne
suffisent pas faire la chasse aller
chercher l'électorat identitaire
islamophobes sont sortir le karcher nous
dire que mariette n'est pas voilée c'est
pour rattraper les égouts aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin le candidat qui
incarne quelque chose moi ce soutien
aujourd'hui la candidature de christiane
taubira et quand on le voit on sent que
c'est quelqu'un qui veut porter une
france humanis tolérante fondée sur les
valeurs de la république avec une vision
qui consiste à donner plus à ceux qui en
ont moins donc on est dans une autre
vision dans une france higgins terre une
france qui reconnaît aussi les
discriminations une france qui reconnaît
les inégalités territoriales aujourd'hui
moi quand j'écoute mme pécresse je peux
vous dire que oui ils ont intérêt à
s'inquiéter au niveau de son camp parce
que elle n'incarne pas ça donc oui
emmanuel macron à une forte chance de
récupérer cet électorat david aviez vice
qu'est ce que vous répondez quand vous
entendez emmanuel macron de toute façon
est de droite alors quelle est la
différence aujourd'hui avec valérie
pécresse
magnanac on est à droite qui était quand
même
ministres et collaborateurs de françois
hollande socialiste il a dans son équipe
beaucoup de socialistes et toute la
toute la technostructure à l'elysée
comme dans les ministères sont sont des
responsables socialistes donc voilà il
ya une très mauvaise analyse / / lesure
ce qu'il incarne et sur ce qu'il est
réellement on a un président de centre
gauche mais c'est un président qui a
fait ses classes au parti socialiste qui
l'a ensuite vidé de sa substance et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui le ps
n'existe plus peuplés salle taubira même
christiane taubira si elle est candidate
elle plafonne à 2 2 ou 3%
voilà moi je veux bien entendre encore
une fois toutes les critiques il faut
quand même juste avoir une vraie vision
de ce qu'est le paysage politique
français
merci quand on voit bruno le maire
gérald darmanin c'est vrai que c'est des
ministres qui auraient pu travailler
avec vers les pétales si nathan
il joue aujourd'hui sont ce sont des
milices populaires mais ils sont
effectivement issu des rangs de la
droite c était des débauchages
successifs
mais voilà c'est malheureusement il
reste quand même un ancien ministre de
france paul en
vente il a été son secrétaire général de
l'elysée il ya encore une fois beaucoup
de la technostructure
dort marché sont des anciens socialistes
je pense à ses enfants je pense à à tous
ceux qui de près ou de loin concours à
l'action et emmanuel macron soit au
gouvernement ou au parlement ou non
voilà il ya une technostructure encore
une fois de centre gauche emmanuel
macron est un ancien socialiste
et là dessus on a de vraies divergences
on ne peut pas dire que
p13 se distingue peu d'emmanuel marron
elle n'a fait que justement depuis le
début de ce mandat l'attaqué et par des
contre-propositions souvent d'ailleurs
qui sont reprises y compris xavier
bertrand quand il avait lancé le chèque
carburant qui a été reprise par le
gouvernement donc on n'est quand même
pas dans la dans la dans la complicité
on l'a on est dans la contre-proposition
certaine surprise d'ailleurs
juste avant les élections
présidentielles de façon assez écoutés
mais il ya une vraie différence je vous
rassure entre l ère
du nord excellent voulait réagir
jusqu'à preuve du contraire d'eric
woerth la maire de calais se sont quand
même pas des élus de dos de gauche donc
il ya une réalité aujourd'hui des
magnans japon mais les français le
considèrent comme étant le président des
riches président de droite est ce que
l'on se dit aujourd'hui la difficulté
qu'a rassemblé sa propre famille
politique et c'est vrai qu'il ya le
phénomène aussi des personnes qui
réfléchissent pas car la part des deux
présents tient mais qu'ils
réfléchissaient aux élections
législatives pourquoi certains
certains montrent des républicains par
du côté de maquereaux je pense que
magali pécresse aurait été à 20% dans
les sondages beaucoup seraient pas
partis donc aussi à la calcule aussi
l'étoile vous voyez c'est n'y a pas une
stabilité dans cette famille politique
et encore moins des convictions fermes
et c'est vrai que les plus nous dérider
républicains ne se reconnaissent pas
dans le discours de valérie pécresse
vous ai cités tout à l'heure lamara
marianne qui n'est pas voilée donc on
entend
récupérer la théorie en remplacement
alors que tout le monde sait que si
c'est complètement fou
c'était complètement fou comment un
candidat de droite qui se tirent
gauchistes qui devrait incarner la
droite républicaine et ré puisse
utiliser justement ces éléments de
langage dans sa campagne il s'agissait
d'un grand meeting qui descend c'est
redonner un nouveau souffle à sa
campagne moi j'estime peu aujourd'hui et
qui peut-être pécresse le veut
s'orienter vers l'électorat identitaire
l'électorat islamophobes les restes des
rectorats et qui qui pensent que le
grand emplacement existe
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est là aussi
elle perd au nombre de ces de ses
soutiens qui sont beaucoup plus
numérique et qui se retrouvent
mais comme je vous dis aujourd'hui la
priorité des français mais pas tout ça
et on voit toutes ces petites phrases
tous ces arrangements de personnes qui
réfléchissent au coup d'après alors
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
d'hommes et de femmes qui sont en
capacité de nous porter une réelle
vision de politique pour notre pays à
des personnes qui pensent à leur
carrière de quel côté ils sont les mieux
placés pour être élu lors des prochaines
élections alors david xavier weiss
répondait justement c'est vrai qu'on
entend effectivement ce matin des
reproches notamment aux reproches à
valérie pécresse d'avoir repris ce terme
grand remplacement ses positions sa
droitisation finalement son discours
qu'est ce que vous répondez
sur ces la wii une incohérence ne peut
pas dire qu'elle était pressée rejoindre
à coup sûr sur la gauche alors qu on lui
reproche en même temps d'avoir des
thématiques de droite assumé / / lesure
sur le voile mais je suis désolé je je
je je serai jamais de ceux qui vont
défendre l'imposition du voile du voile
islamique dans dans le sport ou ailleurs
valérie pécresse défend la laïcité elle
a toujours défendu la laïcité y compris
quand elle était payante de région elle
a interdit le père finit contre des élus
de gauche qui eux veulent préfèrent pour
des raisons électorales souvent être
complice de 2,2 ce jeu là chacun sa
vision sur la laïcité moi j'ai une
vision assez à six défenseurs comme
valérie pécresse de la laïcité c'est pas
votre cave et enfin voilà chacun à
chacun peut avoir une vision différente
de celle ci encore une fois je trouve
que l'on imposé le voile à des jeunes
filles qui n'ont pas demandé à être
complice de ça c'est pas forcément être
très républicain violent excellent
finalement elle a réussi à marquer sa
différence avec les idées de la
république en marge puisque on en débat
ce matin
les révélations concernant le voile ou
concernant quelques aspects concernant
son caisson son cap et
et notamment celui de sa vision de la
laïcité ou de la sécurité qui a été
également au coeur de son meeting
s'agit pas d'une vision de la laïcité il
s'agit d'aller chercher comme jeudi
l'électorat qui marchés et nombre
certains de ses soutiens en reprenant
des thématiques qui sont des thématiques
de la droite identitaire réactionnaire
islamophobe moi je vois pas ce que ça a
pendant un projet politique dans un
discours dans un des bars le fait de
dire que marianne n'est pas voilée
regardez j'ai une marianne juste
derrière moi moi j'ai jamais il n'y a
pas de projet de voir les mariés a nommé
aujourd'hui ce qui est sûr et certain
c'est que valérie pécresse est en perte
de vitesse au sein même de sa part est
politique elle et vous à voir donc elle
va elle va chercher l'extrême droite et
va chercher la droite identitaire et
l'oubli les fondamentaux de des
principes de la république la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité aujourd'hui nous
sommes pas envahis par une civilisation
donc zemmour l'a déjà fait entre eux moi
je pense que c'est une nouvelle
stratégie parce que les gens qui votent
eric zemmour ils préféreront toujours
l'original à la copie donc un moment je
pense que nous avons besoin d'hommes et
de femmes qui sont en capacité
d'incarner autre chose jeudi c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je soutiens la
candidature depuis saintes au virage et
pas fin un choix en fonction des
sondages on fait des choix de conviction
dans quelle société souhaitons nous
vivre et ce qu'on estime que en france
on est réellement menacée par une autre
civilisation
je pense que non et vous êtes tous ceux
conscient qu'il s'agit bien de flattr un
électorat à des fins purement
électoralistes donc les français ils ne
veulent pas de ça et je pense que cette
élection présidentielle heureusement la
vraie campagne n'a pas commencé parce
que vous savez que deux français sur
trois ne savent pas pour qui voter
aujourd'hui donc il ya un électorat
encore abstentionnistes et un électorat
indécis qu'il faut aller chercher je ne
pense pas que c'est en répétant ce que
répète nous aimons c'est en répétant ce
que répète marine le pen que madame
pécresse réussira en tout cas incarner
le le mot de la fin il nous reste il
nous reste très peu de temps le mot de
la fin d'avis xavier weiss justement
peut-être sur sur ses réserves de voix
elle est où cette réserve chez les
abstentionnistes
aujourd'hui il ya effectivement à
convaincre les abstentionnistes même si
on sait très bien que cette élection
présidentielle ne passionnera à beaucoup
de français on sait que s'il ya deux
aujourd'hui 2 français sur 3 1 des
cygnes noirs à un français sur trois qui
n'ira pas voter malheureusement parce
que l'offre mâcon ne séduit pas moins ce
qu'on pense et comme beaucoup pendant
longtemps on a opposé emmanuel macron à
marine le pen dans les sondages et on a
toujours dit que le match était plié en
entre ces deux là ces deux là ne
n'adhère plus ne font plus adhérer à la
vie politique ayant dérogé est la seule
alternative pour ne pas que ce match se
rejoue encore une fois encore une fois
c'est valérie pécresse qui est la seule
aujourd'hui en capacité d'être au second
tour et de pouvoir battre les manuels
maintenu si vous prenez les amours il
est battu très largement et si vous
prenez marine le pen elle aussi battue
très largement la seule qu'on capacités
au second tour de battre emmanuel mâcon
et de créer une réelle alternance c'est
valérie pécresse alors vous pouvez lui
faire tout les coups il reproche que
vous voulez moi je pense quelle défense
de la laïcité
grande quand on parle de lui quand on
parle du voile je suis désolé je ne
serai jamais de ceux qui seront du côté
ci impose le voilà encore une fois des
jeunes filles dont ce n'est pas le choix
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté de
débattre ce matin sur notre antenne
merci à vous david xavier weiss adjoint
à la maire de levallois perret les
républicains merci à vous dieu nord
excellent maire de villetaneuse vous
avez choisi de soutenir christiane
taubira pour cette présidence